[United States Coast Guard Training Film.
Nonclassified.
Copyright 1944 by Paramount Pictures Inc.]
[The Inside Story]
[Foreword.
The most misunderstood of all human ills are
those due to problems of the mind.
People still react to many of the false ideas
of past ages.]
[There are, frankly, definite mental illnesses
of various sorts but the source of most mental
problems is simply emotional disturbance.]
[This causes as much if not more human pain
and suffering and maladjustment of the person
than does organic illness.]
[It is, of course, impossible to fully cover
this subject in any single book or picture,
but this presentation, made for you,]
[endeavors to clarify the most common, fundamental
troubles that beset us as a result of emotional
upset.]
[A newborn baby is shown]
This is the beginning of Patrick Jones.
From this time on, his life is going to be
a constant conflict.
Reality, necessity, and duty; opposing desires,
dreams, and distractions.
These conflicts exist in every human being,
and we must learn how to deal with them.
Ten years later, he is still immature in thought
and action.
Thinking, acting, Pat Jones, who can raise
more hell than any kid on the block.
[Fire cracker explodes and his father yells
at him]
He has plenty of fun, some of it not exactly
in accord with adult ideas of peace and quiet,
but all in the routine pattern of boyhood.
It makes him feel a little important to heckle
his father.
Not in any spirit of mean-ness, but because
the old man represents authority and discipline.
[Fire cracker explodes under a tin can]
Yes, over the years Dad has learned that fire
cracker shooting must be restricted at times.
And this is going to hurt Dad more than it
does Pat.
[Dad brings Pat inside the house]
As Pat grows older, he finds it pleasant to
have people make a fuss over him.
Like the time when he won first prize in an
interscholastic contest.
Or when he hurt his knee in the championship
football game and so covered himself with
glory that everyone made over and waited on
him.
He was the four-star local hero and he loved
it, as who wouldn't.
Inside himself, unconsciously, Pat will always
carry with him this memory.
And Dad was proud as a peacock, he showed
the newspaper clippings until they were worn
out.
This is home and it's great, friendly and
protective.
Home means Mom's deep-dish apple pie, so good
Dad always had three pieces.
And it's sitting around listening to the radio,
playing a little gin rummy with the old man.
It's where he can call up Margie, whenever
he likes.
Ask her to the movies, or to a dance, or just
down to the drugstore for a soda.
Or if he feels like being alone, he can go
up to his own room.
There's something mighty comfortable about
your own room.
And he's a man on his own, too.
Paying his own way, earning his own living.
Patrick Jones, junior foreman, holding down
a job, with a paycheck every Saturday, and
a good one for a guy of his age.
Jones: Patrick R. Jones.
Paymaster: Patrick R. Jones.
I see they're closing you out Pat?
Jones: Closing me out?
I quit.
Paymaster: Bill Goss.
Goss: Bill Goss.
Sorry you're leavin', Jones.
Jones: I'm getting a better job.
So long.
Narrator: And he could quit his job whenever
he liked, for whatever reason he liked.
Overnight, his home life is left behind and
he's one of millions of men, each one a Seaman
Jones.
That means he isn't necessarily our Seaman
This Seaman Jones may have graduated from
one of the ritziest colleges in New England.
Or he could be Seaman Rabinovitz, who never
made it beyond sixth grade of a public school.
This one could've been one of the seven Swenson
kids from a farm.
Or O'Brien, who never knew his folks and was
raised in an orphanage.
But, whoever a man is you can tell a lot about
him by what's in his heart.
Seaman Jones may be a little along in a couple
of years and have a wife and kids.
Then again, he could just be a kid himself,
and still lookin' them over, if you know what
I mean.
Or he could be the boy who's been going steady
with the girl who's always been his, and always
will be.
[Take care of yourself.
My darling]
So let's look at the inside story of this
Seaman Jones.
Who's gone from this -- to this.
[Patrick shown at his old job, to him in a
Coast Guard uniform]
From Mom's deep-dish apple pie to a mess line.
From his own room, to this.
[A full bunk dorm with men wrestling each
other]
Noise, confusion, no privacy.
The
change is a big one and he's having a hard
time adjusting himself to this new life.
Seaman Jones is homesick, unhappy, and disturbed.
Lots of things seem to be combining to worry
him.
He feels that he is being unfairly neglected
by his family and his girl.
He's had no mail for four days now.
And it seems as though he's the only one who
misses.
He's having trouble concentrating on his class
work.
Doesn't seem able to follow.
And he's the boy who used to win the silver
cups in high school.
All-in-all, this is no picnic, says Seaman
Jones.
He finds himself panicky and lost in a crowd
of countless men, where everybody looks alike
and is treated alike.
No glory here like the time he was a football
hero.
He's really worried about himself.
So much so, that one night...
[Jones is sleeping in the bunk and talks in
his head]
Jones: Mustn't forget my general orders.
[He hears yelling of orders]
Jones: How will I pass inspection?
Will I get my liberty this weekend?
Are we going out tomorrow?
Will I get my stripes?
Exam coming up tomorrow.
Gee, I've got the jitters.
Am I going nuts?
Exams, drills, inspections, exams, drills
-
[Jones wakes up]
Jones: My God, maybe I'm going nuts; maybe
they'll drive me crazy!
Narrator: Then, on top of all his other problems,
Seaman Jones, who'd always been a gay, friendly
guy, who got along with other people
found himself unable to enter into the general
easy companionship of the men with whom he
was living and working.
[Men gambling]
Instead of joining in, he resented the sometimes
loud, rowdy fun in the barracks and nobody
seemed to care how he felt.
Well, if all that isn't enough to trouble
one guy, all of the sudden the knee he twisted
in that grand and glorious football game went
back on him.
It really hurt, plenty.
But at least he can have that taken care of.
And a mighty good doctor looks it over with
the greatest care.
But the doctor can't find anything organically
wrong with the knee.
Now the most startling thing about this upset
is that Seaman Jones isn't goldbricking.
His knee really hurts and it's not imagination
either.
He feels the pain, that's how he knows it's
there.
That's important and it's frightening, too
because, on top of trouble with studies, and
nightmares, and loneliness, what can be wrong?
He better do something about it.
He does
the most sensible thing he could possibly
do: goes to the mental health department and
sees the psychiatrist.
For naturally, an emotional upset must be
treated differently from an organic illness.
Jones tells his story and the doctor is neither
surprised nor alarmed, for this isn't a new
story to him, amazing as it is to Jones.
And he knows the answer.
An answer that Jones can understand because
there aren't a lot of strange highfaluting
terms.
Doctor: Today, we're making a scientific study
of mind and we're finding some very encouraging
things.
Now, this nervous breakdown that you're afraid
of, for instance.
Well, the truth is nobody has a nervous breakdown,
ever.
Jones: They don't?
Doctor: Nerves, our physical nerves, don't
break.
We do get into mental and emotional moods
that make us pretty unhappy, the results of
all the difficulties and conflicts that beset
us,
that we've reacted to, that we've had difficulty
adjusting to.
Now, your symptoms suggest that you are in
such a mood.
A mood of anxiousness.
Even your physical symptoms, like the aching
knee you told me about, can have an emotional
cause.
I'll explain that in a moment.
Anxiousness is quite a common mood.
It makes a person focus his attention much
more closely on himself.
Perhaps he notices his heart beating or his
muscles tensing.
Jones: Yes.
Doctor: People often think in this mood of
anxiousness that it's leading to a mental
illness.
Actually, it almost never does.
Perhaps I can help you if I give you an idea
of how your mind works.
You see, Jones, emotions actually can cause
real physical pain.
The conscious mind is a pleasant sunny place
where normal thoughts have free reign.
The unconscious mind is dark and mysterious
and harbors such thoughts as:
"I'm lonesome.
Nobody pays any attention to me.
I wish I were dead.
I must be losing my mind."
These thoughts are constantly trying to get
to the conscious mind to get past the censor
who polices the band.
[Cartoon of characters scaling wall guarded
by censor] It's his job to keep them out.
[A walnut was thrown at the censor's head]
Censor: Hey!
Doctor: Here's a little thought that keeps
popping up.
[Walnut turns into a metaphoric thought]
Walnut-boy: I'm lonesome.
[Censor throws thought back to unconscious
side]
Suicide man: I wished I was dead.
Censor: Huh?
What did you say?
Suicide man: I said I wished I was dead.
[This thought shoots himself in the head with
a toy gun]
Blind man: Uh, I must be stupid; I just can't
see things clearly.
[Blind man falls over the wall into conscious
mind]
Censor: Outside, bums!
Two-headed man: I'm my own worst enemy!
Fearful man: Stop pickin' on me!
Someone's always pickin' on me!
Unicyclist: Nobody pays any attention to me.
They're blind to real talent!
Huh, watch this.
[Unicyclist cycles very fast but runs over
someone and his head is blown off]
Man who got run over: I must be losing my
mind!
Censor: Holy cats!
I must be losing mine!
[Censor catches all of the thoughts and sends
them back to the unconscious side of the wall]
Censored out of the conscious mind, these
self-pitying thoughts tumble into the lap
of Old Unconscious Mind,
the dormant parent of all your emotions, and
arouse him with their clamor.
[A sleeping giant is woken up by the thoughts]
They goad him to find another way for them
to assert themselves on your conscious mind.
So, this brute, who never forgets anything
that ever happened to you, remembers a certain
incident.
Unconscious Mind: Hmm ... hmm ...
[Flashback of when Jones hurt his knee playing
in the football championship]
Which got you a nice lot of sympathetic attention
in the past.
An incident which your conscious mind may
have completely forgotten, but your unconscious
remembers and now he knows just what to do.
Unconscious Mind: I've got it, boys!
Into the car with you!
[Excited talking amongst the self-pitying
thoughts as they get into the car]
[Switches: Nervous System.
Transportation Co.
Arm.
Neck.
Eye.
Pelvis.
Head.
Ear.
Feet.
Knee]
[Unconscious Mind pushes the car into a tunnel
and flips the switch labeled knee]
[Car travels down the spine to the knee]
[Thoughts come out of car with demolishing
tools and begin to hit the knee]
Two-Headed man: Why didn't we think of this
before?
Walnut boy: I'm not lonesome anymore!
Man on jackhammer: I've got some attention
now, this'll really make him hurt!
Doctor: And that's why your knee hurts, even
though there's nothing physically wrong with
it.
Jones: Well, I'm sure glad to hear that.
Doctor: A lot of boys feel about the way you
do.
There's another seaman in here a few days
ago named Scott.
A big strapping lad, who during his civilian
days never had anything wrong with him.
He won golden glove tournaments and was a
very pretty fighter indeed.
[Flashback of Scott knocking out the other
fighter and winning the match]
Doctor: Then he landed in the Coast Guard
and found himself no more important than any
other seaman.
He found himself being ordered around by a
Petty Officer half his size; being told what
to do and how to do it.
Having his hat straightened for him and even
having the lint dusted off his clothes.
He, a champion, in his own right.
And even in the classroom, he found himself
thrown for a loss by simple navigation.
He just couldn't turn out an adequate notebook.
So, one day he turned up at sick bay with
a bad stomach ache.
A
physical exam, x-ray, and laboratory studies
proved there was nothing physically wrong,
so he was sent to the psychiatrist.
What went on in his mind was something like
this ...
He had a lot of self-pitying thoughts running
around in his mind for all his toughness.
And of course, he wouldn't let his conscious
mind think that.
[Censor catches self-pitying thoughts and
throws them back to the unconscious mind side]
Doctor: The censor chases them into his unconscious
mind and Old Man Unconscious decides what
Seaman Scott needs
is a darn good foolproof excuse for not doing
so well right now.
And he takes care of that in his own way.
[Self-pitying thoughts get into car]
[Switches: Nervous System.
Transportation Co.
Arm.
Neck.
Eye.
Pelvis.
Head.
Ear.
Feet.
Stomach]
[Unconscious Mind pushes the car into a tunnel
and flips the switch labeled stomach]
[Car travels down to the stomach]
Jackhammer man: Hey fellas come on!
Let's get off of there!
Get to work!
Come on!
[Thoughts come out of car with demolishing
tools and chat excitedly]
Fearful man: They're always pickin' on me,
now it's my turn to do the picking!
Doctor: Everybody has emotional disturbances
and nobody is really strong enough to control
his emotions absolutely.
I have some notes here that I'll give you.
Look them over.
They may clear up some of the things that
have been bothering you.
Jones: Thank you, sir.
Narrator: So, Seaman Jones did study the notes
and found them even more helpful than he'd
hoped.
They were interesting, understandable, and
they made sense.
[Mental Health]
[Inside of us, there is always a battle going
on between what we want to do, and what we
have got to do...]
Seaman: Get the professor, would ya?
Jones: Some military doctor gave me, how to
go nuts in three easy lessons, or something.
Kelley: Hey, you ought to give it to some
of my Petty Officers.
I've got a guy over me that's a real Frankenstein.
You know it worries me.
Jones: Oh yeah, well, it says here that:
"Maybe you're blaming your Petty Officer because
you have a sneaking feeling that you can't
keep up with the rest of the fellas."
Kelley: You mean it's me that's nuts?
Jones: Everybody does funny things.
Listen to this:
"Inside of us, there is always a battle going
on between what we want to do, and what we've
got to do."
Kelley: Yeah, that's the way I feel alright.
Somehow, whenever I get a dirty job to do,
no matter what kind, maybe like swabbing down
the deck, I can't seem to think straight.
All of the sudden I ain't Seaman Kelley no
more, I'm somebody else.
I look at all that deck that's gotta be swabbed,
and ugh.
Narrator: And his mind is a million miles
away as he dreams himself into an out-of-the-world
hero.
This time as a spy in Hirohito's palace.
A sort of sea-going Dick Tracy, eh Kelley?
[Kelley lifts up part of his shirt to reveal
a button]
[Secret Operator 22 1/2]
[Kelley continues swabbing the floor]
[Palace doors open to reveal Hirohito]
[Kelley pulls out a gun from his pants]
[Kelley goes after Hirohito with a gun]
[Gunshots are heard]
Of course there has to be a reward for a daring
deed like that.
[Cheering]
And it's a real double barreled homecoming
for, yup, Admiral Kelly, right down Fifth
Avenue.
Crowd: Yay, Kelley!
Come on, Kelley!
And this is so real he can hear the crowd
yelling his name.
Petty officer: Kelley!
Kelley!
Get to work!
Kelley: Yeah, sure.
Sure, sure.
That's why I can't stand that Petty Officer.
Jones: Well, is it because he's a bad egg,
or just because he had to pull you back to
reality?
Kelley: No, don't get me in no argument, son.
Well, all right, maybe it was.
Come on, give out with more of our problems,
Mr. Antony.
Jones: Well, maybe some of you guys don't
like these man-to-man combat drills.
Seaman: I always did hate them.
Kelley: Well look, you don't need to be no
sawbones to figure that one out.
You got...ah...inferiority dingus.
Yea, it's like what they call an inferiority
complication.
Jones: It says here: "When you have a feeling
of inadequacy, when you feel you can't keep
up with the competition,"
"you may begin to blame the task you're having
trouble with, instead of realizing it is your
own weakness that is troubling you."
Seaman: Well, does it tell me how I can get
cured?
Second seaman: Well sure, you've got to know
something about it.
Now everyone has inferiority.
It's not that that's bad.
Inferiority helps us a lot of times because
we try to improve ourselves.
Now if we do something that turns out good,
that helps us, but there's always inferiority
in all people.
Seaman: Yeah, but that's just horse sense.
Jones: The doc says, "Mental health is just
applying common sense to your emotional problems."
Kelley: Sure, only books got to put it in
fancy words, so the guy who wrote it can get
three bucks a copy for it.
Jones: Hey, get this: "It is hard to recognize
jealousy in oneself."
"For example, most of us secretly wish we
could be All-American athletes.
"Because we can't, we like to say athletes
are dumbbells, all brawn and no brains."
Seaman: And that, my fellow scientist, is
what is known as the sour grapes complex.
Second seaman: That's maybe why we say most
beautiful girls are dumb.
Kelley: You think that's bad?
Jones: No, but if we know what it is, we can
use it to help us to get ahead.
Seaman: Say, where did you get that fortune-telling
bunch of notes anyway?
Jones: The doc gave it to me.
A couple of weeks ago I started to get ... Well,
I thought my nerves would snap.
Seems they can't snap.
Your nervous system is just like anything
else.
It gets tired and upset, but a good night's
sleep, or a little play and relaxation, it's
okay again.
Nerves don't break; it's our feelings that
get the best of us.
Seaman: Say, no kidding.
You know what I'm afraid of?
Second seaman: What, work?
Seaman: No, I'm afraid of being a coward.
Second seaman: Gee, me too.
Seaman: No, sometimes I can't think of anything
else.
I know you'll think I'm a dope or something,
but sometimes I go to chapel and I sit there,
and I start sweating.
Seaman: And I say, "Keep me from being a coward.
Oh God,
"what am I going to do if I get into action
somewhere and I get so scared I turn traitor?"
Narrator: That's a natural terrible fear,
the fear of doing this: running away.
A fear we all have.
Yet it's a normal fear.
For it's deep-rooted in every animal.
We call it the instinct of self-preservation.
Animals react to it instinctively in order
to protect themselves.
So we know that we may be afraid, but fear
and cowardice are not the same.
In fact, fear is an emotion which has always
protected us.
For example, here's an American submarine
cruising quietly.
Suddenly, an enemy bomb crashes into it.
It doesn't explode, but it's live, and it
can any second, and it's jammed in an almost
inaccessible place below.
Only this skinny boy can get at it.
He must remove the detonator even though he
doesn't know how.
He's scared blue.
He can be guided only by instructions from
a loud speaker.
But here's a great thing about fear.
Sometimes, in this case for instance, it can
actually help.
For it causes an instantaneous change to occur
in our bodies so that every muscle and organ
goes into high gear,
to help us through the emergency, as it's
helping this seaman,
while he's literally got the sub and the lives
of the crew in his hands.
Stimulated by fear, the heart pumps faster
to carry more blood through the arteries.
The glands step up their secretions of vitalizing
fluids into the system.
And he's doing what he has to do, as frightened
as you will ever be.
Fear is acting helpfully to heighten all responses.
Waste materials which might slow us down are
quickly thrown off and there comes an amazing
intensity of concentration to carry us through
emergencies.
You can see the terror in this man's face,
but by stepping up his physical reactions
to help him through the most dangerous crisis
of his life, fear has become his ally instead
of his enemy.
Aided by fear, he's done it.
Now Seaman Jones, and the rest of his mates
who were troubled, understand more fully some
of the sources and causes of their worries.
And as a result, Jones is no longer lonely
and out of things.
He's one of the guys.
He's learned what his mistakes were and corrected
some of them.
He's adjusted to his new environment and he's
doing all right.
The same is true of Seaman Scott.
He's all straightened out now and is doing
a swell job.
He even thinks of those bugaboo Petty Officers
as good guys now.
And this one's a swell ping pong player, too.
Scott has finally found the right outlets
for his energy and ambition.
And Kelly the dreamer, he's not dreaming now.
He's having a good time and he's studying
hard, for he's learned that it's only through
our own efforts that we achieve real satisfaction.
Yes, all people must learn to live and work
in harmony, must assume new responsibilities
and take pride in their duties.
That's what is now reflected in these men's
faces as they get combat orders.
Anderson looks confident.
Kelly is alert and ready.
Scott is cool, steady warrior, and Seaman
Jones is going after new recognition.
So then, we see how trouble is stayed, as
we learn even a little about our minds,
and thereby protect ourselves against some
of the unconscious trends to which we are
subject.
Sound mental health is our nation's greatest
asset, and this we must maintain.
With it, let us have pride.
Pride in our corps, and in our service.
And we must have faith and hope, in our cause,
our way of life, and for a better world tomorrow.
[The End.
MG-4068.
1944]